You never know what is around the corner...
...unless you peek.
Hold someone's hand while you do it.
You'll feel less scared.
You can't do this alone.
Besides, it's much more fun to succeed and fail with other people.
You can blame them when things go wrong.
Take your risks now.
As you grow older, you become more fearful and less flexible.
Try to keep your mind open to possibilities...
...and your mouth closed on matters that you don't know about.
Limit your "always" and your "nevers".
Continue to share your heart with people,...
...even if it's been broken.
When you feel scared, hold someone's hand...
...and look into their eyes.
And when you feel brave,...
...do the same thing.
You are all here because you are smart...
...and you are brave.
And if you add kindness...
...and the ability to change a tire,...
...you almost make up the perfect person.